henri leconte en finale du tournoi de
roland garros c'est chose faite depuis
un peu plus d'une heure henri leconte
l'a emporté en trois sets face à un
suédois qui n'avaient pas digéré
semble-t-il son match d'hier face à ivan
lendl images et commentaires avec jean
ma mère en direct de roland garros ça ne
marchait pas je suis franc avec vous il
ya quelques instants
peut-être même qui signait ce que nous
avons roland garros en direct je suis là
je suis là voyez ça marche toujours sont
émus les misères de la technique alors
montrez nous la balle de match et la
victoire d'henri leconte on va vous la
montrer parce que ça c'est assez
fabuleux c'est quand même le cinquième
français qui va aujourd'hui disputer une
finale de l'euro de roland garros
nous allons le voir tout de suite après
marcel bernard pierre d'armand patrick
proisy yannick noah est maintenant oui
le comte henri leconte qui a fait
plaisir à la france
mal à l'aise dans son premier set il a
retrouvé tout son tennis dans le
deuxième sérieux appliqués concentrés
henri leconte a fait un match je dirais
dans la ligne de toute sa semaine
c'est-à-dire avec des débuts un peu
hésitants mais dès fin en apothéose le
pauvre svensson n'a pas pesé lourd cet
après-midi pour henri leconte est aux
finalistes thériault rêve qu'il a
préparé depuis longtemps
il a vieilli
en finale il ne rencontrera pas agassi
puisqu'avant agassi a perdu mais
aujourd'hui il est devenu le chouchou de
roland garros fair play au point
d'applaudir les belles balles de son
adversaire canonnier aussi mais cet
après midi agassi a présumé de ses
forces
il a certes tiré le premier mais wieland
air a lancé la dernière salle en fin de
partie c'est tombé très fort mais agassi
a reçu une pluie d'applaudissements
à très bientôt monsieur agassi voilà
merci jean et on se retrouve dans les
jours qui viennent